Raz: Good morning, everybody.
So my name is Itai.
I'm an engineer from
Google Tel Aviv.
And I'm going to talk about
how to implement
your own data source
for the Google visualization
API.
I'm gonna start with
some introduction
about the API itself
in general.
And then I'm gonna focus on
data source--
the concept of data source
and what it means to be--
to get Data Source for API.
Then I'm gonna talk more about
the open source library,
the Java library that
we've just announced.
And later on,
we'll have Jesse Lorenz
from Salesforce,
and he'll talk about
the implementation
of Data Source.
And Q&A in the end.
So I'll start with
a few words about
the Google Visualization API.
I know that some of you
know it,
and some of you were
in yesterday's session too,
but I just want to make sure
that everybody knows
what I'm talking about.
So this API is a tool
that is used to visualize
structural data
over the web.
In general, it's a library
of many visualizations
from different
implementations,
Flash based or image based
or JavaScript based.
But all of them share
the same API.
So you load them on
the same way
and you interact with them
the same way.
It's all JavaScript based API.
You don't care about
the implementation
of the actual code,
and it's true for
all of them that
the same way
to configure them,
to interact with them,
and to manage events
if there are events.
And one thing that is more
important to this session
is that they share
the same data table model.
So no matter again what--
if it's the pie chart
in JavaScript
or the motion chart in Flash,
they share the same class
that represent the data,
and this class called
data table.
You load it from the--
when you load the JavaScript API
from the library.
And it's a very simple class.
It has rows and columns.
Each column has a type
that can be string numbered--
date and time and so on.
A pretty fine set of types.
And each column has a type,
so all of the sales
from this type--
from this column
share the same type.
You may have as many rows
as you want.
Usually, it will not be
above a few thousand
because then the browser
will just fail to visualize it
and to create
the visualization width.
So let's see just
a few examples.
So there is a gallery
in our documentation
out of all of the charts.
This is a very simple example
of--
this is the example page
of the bar chart you can--
this is--sorry.
This is a Flash based--
I'm sorry.
JavaScript based,
so you can interact with it
and get events when
the user interacts and so on.
The code is very simple
to create it.
Most of the code--
this is the code that you see--
all of the HTML page
that you need to have
in order to see this chart.
Mainly what you see here
is the--
most of the lines
in the middle
is the creation of
the data table
and populating it with data.
The first row that you see
is loading the JSAPI loader,
the JavaScript loader
of Google.
Then we call the Google
load function
to load the library--
the library of
the visualization.
And the specific packages
shows what you want,
and then again,
we create a data table.
We populate it with data,
in this case locally,
just with JavaScript calls--
functions.
And then we create a chart
and draw it with
this data table.
And that's it.
Another example
that I want to show
is this one in which
I have iGoogle
that takes the data from
some remote data source.
And I'll explain, of course,
later, what it means.
Still it's one child
that you might know
from Google Finance.
It's an annotated timeline,
we call it--
it's time-based access.
And the Ys, you may have
as many data series
that you want
with the notations.
And the last example here
is this one.
This is the motion chart,
in which you can see bubbles
moving with different X and Y
in size and colors
and with the timeline.
So it has, like,
five dimensions.
In this case,
what you can see
is that all of the data
is taken from the Google
spreadsheets behind it.
So it has many columns,
and it can set
which columns means what,
it can change the,
I don't know,
the color to be not the region
but something else.
And you see that it changes
on the fly.
I can change it to be
a bar chart
instead of bubbles and so on.
But what I wanted to show you
that I can take this one
and add it--okay.
Add it to iGoogle.
And then,
in addition
to the time series
that you just saw,
I have now this motion chart,
that hopefully
will be loaded in a second.
And you see just
the same configuration
that I just set,
I have it here.
And the nice thing about it
is that, as you can see here,
I can edit the settings,
and the first setting
is data source URL.
And now it's taking
the data from the spreadsheet,
as we just saw, so if
I change the spreadsheet data,
it will take--
it will affect this one too.
So you can create data--
you can create dashboards
of users that are taking--
that are built from charts
from many other data--
many different data sources.
And each one of them
is the live data.
So it's not hardcore data
in a page,
it's something that gets
live data
from Google spreadsheets.
Or what I want to show now
in this session
is that you can actually build
your own data source.
So the data can be taken
from your organizational data
including all of
the nice features
that are already
in the data source.
[clears throat]
So again, you can create
a data table locally
as we saw in the example
by just creating
a JavaScript data table
object,
and then add columns and rows
and set the values.
Alternatively,
you can use a JSON notation,
which is much faster
in the browser.
But it's a bit harder
to implement,
to write,
to generate this code.
But the effect
is just the same.
And in addition, you can use
the remote data source.
Then you get all of
the good stuff
that is written here.
You don't have to have
all the data in your page,
but it's taken every time
from a different place--
the live data
that are in the data source.
You've got a query language
that will explain--
I will explain later
and show.
But in general,
it means that
you don't have to create
any variant of the data.
Instead, you create
a single data table
on the service side,
and the data source implements
the query language.
So the user you can just
type in another parameter
to the URL
and specify the queries
that you want to do
the manipulation,
the data manipulation.
If you want to do only
select some--
certain columns
or maybe sort the data
or group it
or whatever you want.
Or to refresh.
It's another feature
of the query.
You can set the query
with auto refresh
for any time,
any number of seconds
that you want.
And then after these number
of seconds,
the JavaScript automatically
sends another request
to the data source
to see if there is any change
in the data.
And if there is,
it's reflected automatically
in the chart.
It's using the JSON
constructives that we just saw,
so it's much faster
than using the JavaScript
notation of functions.
And the last thing is that
it's a public protocol,
which means that
you can just read it
in the documentation.
It's well documented
and it's--
you can just know how
to implement it.
It's not that complicated.
Even if you want to do it
on your own.
In order to send a query
to a data source, so it's--
from gadget,
it's very simple,
because the gadgets
are already pre-built
to deal with it.
So all we have to do
in the gadget
is to write the URL.
But if you want to do it
in JavaScript,
it's not
much more than this.
You just create a query object
past the URL,
option--already sent
the query language phrase.
And then send it
with a callback,
and when the response
get back from the server,
you just take the response--
take the data table from it
and work with it.
Additionally,
you can also check
if there are any errors
and react to them.
So let's talk
about data source.
So first of all,
as I said,
there is a public documentation
of the format--
the format of the response
and the request of
this protocol.
So it's documented exactly--
all of the fields
and the details
that may be or must be
in the request.
And of course,
of all of the things there are,
they should be in
the response.
It contains information
about errors that may be--
so there is a way
to pass errors, for example,
access denied or any other error
from the client--
from the server
to the client.
So it's not that the client
don't get any response,
but you can pass errors
in there.
And most of the visualization
know how to show them
very nicely
so the user can understand
that something went wrong.
And another thing to say
that there is the new version
with some improvements.
I'm gonna cover some of them.
It's all documented
in our site.
There are some additions
to the query language.
So now it supports
some calculated columns
and Scholar functions.
So if you have a field
from type date,
you can ask to get only
the year part of this date
and so on,
which is very nice
if you want to do some
aggregations.
And in the Java library
that I'm gonna cover later,
it's all fully implemented.
So if you use this library,
you get the full query language
in your data source
without the need to write
a single line of code
that deals with it.
A few words about security
because--
just to make sure
that it's clear.
When you use a data source,
it means that from
the visualization,
a request is sent
to bring the data.
It's not included
in the page itself, as we said.
And this means that as--
on the same wave that
you send a request
to get this data,
maybe someone else
might try to send a request
to this data.
Until now, we use a technique
called script injection.
Because the advantage of this
is that you can send request
across the domain.
It means that if you get--
if you have your data
on a Google spreadsheet,
or maybe if you have your data
on one site,
but you want to show it
in your blog,
of if you have any public data
that you want everybody
to be accessed--
to be able to read,
so we have to use
this technique.
But the bad side is that
it's a bit easier to get--
for people that you don't want
to get this data
and maybe to get it,
it's not easy,
but it's possible
in some ways.
Now we change to use
in most of the cases as
a default,
a method called XHR.
So the requests are limited
by default to your domain.
By authenticating the user
and making sure
that he has the cookies
that he needs to have,
you can be sure that
the request came from
the same domain that
the data source is.
And since this is
a common use--
use case,
so this is the default.
And we also didn't want people
to have, like,
mistakenly to open
their data source
to other people.
So if you want to change it
and you want other domains
to be able to get this data,
it's very simple to change.
I'll show it later on how you
do it on the service side.
But just know that
the default is that
it's only for the same domain
and you can open it.
There are some other
alternatives to change--
to send the request in.
Once called makeRequest
to enable--
it's something specific
for gadgets.
You can read about it more.
And if you don't specify
any one, any option,
then it's--
we apply some heuristics.
And if we see that
you send the request to
the same domain of
your webpage,
then we use XHR.
If not, we use script
injection.
So the query language
is a bit similar to SQL.
You have a selection
in row ordering and grouping.
And even people think
that it's not possible in SQL.
We don't have all of
the capabilities of SQL,
but it's a very nice set.
And if you have any
data tables
that you want to present
in so many different
visualizations,
you can use it
and it's very easy.
Very easy to use
in the implementation of
the Java,
the Java library.
Of course in addition to this,
you might have some specific
URL parameters.
So in this Google spreadsheet
example,
you see that you specified
the key of the spreadsheet
from which you want to read,
but on top of this
you can add a tq parameter
for the query language
and say,
okay, this is a spreadsheet,
it has, I don't know,
ten columns, but I want
to read only the first
and the second column
because I want a pie chart
that takes only two columns.
So let's have a look
on this Java library.
As a concept,
this is an open source library.
So you can get the code,
you can modify for your needs
and do whatever you want.
It has, again,
as I said, full--
complete support for
the query language.
It has--it contains
some examples.
So if you just load it and--
within, say, an hour,
you can just read through
the documentation
of the Getting Started.
And then you have
working Tomcat,
with all of the configuration
that you need.
And you see
the running example,
and it's very good
to start with this.
Now we can go and create
your own examples
or your own use cases
that are not that simple maybe.
But still, you have something
to start with
and you see real
visualization,
as they're going to show
later on today.
There are utilities
for CSV and MySQL.
So in most--
in many cases,
people have CSV files
on MySQL data tables.
And they want to use
these tables
to visualize this data.
But today,
there is no way to do it.
Okay, you have a CSV file
on your own computer
or on your website.
There is no way to use it
to visualize this data.
What this library provides
is some class that you can,
with very small number
of call lines,
just specify the URL
of these files
or the location
of these files.
And we take it from there.
We take it--
we access these files.
We change it,
we transform them
into the JSON format
of the response
of this protocol.
In the middle,
we take the query that
the user provided
and apply it on top of
this data table.
And all that you have to do
is to specify the exact
location of the file.
I'm gonna show an example
of this.
We have the same for SQL.
As I said by default,
we use the restricted--
same domain mode,
but you can change it
in a single line of code.
You get the source code
and you get jars,
so if you just want to use it
as is
and you don't want
to start looking at the code
or change it,
you just take the jars,
you put them on Tomcat,
are they gonna show now?
And there you go.
And again,
it's well documented,
and there's a user group.
If you have any questions
or comments, you can use it.
So let's have a quick demo.
So first of all,
the documentation--
in the general documentation
of the API,
there is a section describing
this new library.
And if you just go through
the Getting Started,
you'll see a very detailed
explanation
of how to install Tomcat,
how to configure it
for you to have this--
to install all of the things
that you need,
and you are set.
Specifically what I did here,
I just downloaded
the .jar files and--
all of the configuration
that is needed
is to take all of the dependents
in the .jar files
put them in the web directory
of Tomcat,
as you can see here.
In addition, I took
the web XML file,
that is the file that tells
Tomcat where to--
where the application exists,
and added these--
these are mapping for
the servlets.
So I have something
called Simple Example here,
and another one on the bottom
called CSV.
I'm gonna show both of them.
Simple Example is something
that just create
a static table,
and CSV is something that
takes the table from a CSV file.
So let's start with
the Simple Example.
This is all the code
that is here in this servlet
to create the response.
And I'll show in a minute
all of the things
that you can do with
this response.
It's not just a simple table
as it looks.
So what I do here,
I implemented--
I have a servlet called
Simple Example.
Servlet I implemented--
I extended, sorry,
data source servlet.
And it means that
I only need to implement
a single method called
generate data table.
This method gets
a query object,
which is the tq parameter
that the user
may have added to the URL.
We'll select some certain
columns and so on,
and the requests.
You might want to use
the request to know
what the other parameters
the user specified
or get cookies to authenticate
the user and so on.
And the query,
for the moment let's assume
that you can just ignore it.
Later on, I'll show
what you can do with it,
but you don't have to
do anything in order to have
the query language
working for you.
So here in this example,
they just build
the data table object,
add some four columns of
a name, a link,
and a population.
Of a vegetarian,
of a buillon field,
of some animals,
and then I add columns
for each one of these animals,
and that's it.
You can see that down here
that I set the restricted mode
to false,
but just for this example--
again, normally if
you don't do this,
then it will be true.
So let's see the results
of this very nice example.
It looks like this.
So it's not very useful,
at least when you want
to debug your code
and check it and make sure
that you understand
what's going on.
Although this is the right
JSON format of the response.
So let's see what you get
for free here.
The first thing is,
you can change the render,
or what we call it,
to HTML.
So we know not only
to create the JSON format
out of this data table,
but then also to create
a very simple data table,
HTML table.
So when you are on
the development cycle,
you don't have to try
to understand what went wrong.
If you try to visualize it
and something doesn't work,
you can just change
the TQX parameter.
Again, it's all documented
so you don't have
to remember it.
But you change
the output format to HTML
and then you can see
the table
and find out what's going on.
This is one thing.
Another render that there is,
though it's already written
and supported, is CSV.
So you might want to have
a link
just below the chart saying
okay, "I want this data to be--
"I want the user to be able
to download
this data in CSV format."
So you can just--
just below the chart
that displayed this data,
you can have another link
saying, "download this data"
and say--
have the same link of URL--
the same URL,
but without CSV.
And then when
you click on it--
when the user clicks on it,
they get this
save file option
or whatever they want to
do with it.
In addition,
let's change it back to...
HTML.
And let's specify that
we don't want the whole table.
We want only the first column.
So there you go.
Select name,
and you've got the name.
I can also order them
by whatever field they want
or to filter these that--
size equals something
or whatever.
And all of this, again,
just go back to the code.
So...maybe one more thing
to explain about
the code structure.
So there is an example here.
And there is the library
itself.
The call they just show now
is from the examples.
So it just uses all of the code
of the library as is.
It doesn't change it,
it doesn't do anything.
So as you see,
it's just a small example.
Creating the data tables,
starting the data table,
and you get all of
these renders
and all of these query
language for free
without the need
to do anything.
So now let's move on to
a bit more interesting example,
which is this one.
Taking--using a CSV file
and building the table
on top of it.
So what we see here is also
the same kind of servlet--
implement--
I extend data source servlet
and I need to implement
the generate table function,
as you see here.
What I do here--
I read the--
a single parameter
called URL,
which is the URL,
in this case of the CSV file.
And I take the CSV file,
and what I'm doing with it is
I want to make a data table
out of it.
So let's see
how simple it is.
I just create a reader,
a Java reader object.
And giving this URL
so I can work with it,
this is something that
is general Java procedure.
Then I do this thing,
which is interesting.
It's an optional step,
but what I'm doing here is
I get the locale
of the user.
Why it's important?
Because in many times,
as you know with CSV files,
you have dates,
for example.
And dates are written
in CSV files
in different formats,
depending on the URL locale
or the user--
or the owner of the file.
So what I'm doing here is just,
I give this locale
as a parameter to the next--
to the passing of the CSV file.
You don't have to do it.
If you don't do it,
we take some different locale,
but it's quite useful.
And the last thing I do
is I call CSV Data Source
helper.
I read the method.
Okay, this is the reader
and it does everything
that it needs to do
including passing the file,
creating the JSON format.
In the middle,
it takes the query
if the user specified any,
and apply it on this data table.
And there you go.
There is a data table,
and everything is done.
So let's see this example
live.
Oh, just, this is--
I'm going back to
the example I showed before.
So this--
I just showed you here that,
okay, there is a table,
but let's see how it's used.
So this is another--
just a simple HTML page.
It says "Hello! Data Source!"
and show a chart.
This chart is actually
a table,
a table visualization,
not to be mixed with
the data tables
that we just saw.
It's a very rich table,
actually, you can--
the user can select rows
and sort them
and get select event
when something--
when the user interacts
with it.
You can customize it
very well.
It's a very nice tool.
I want to show you
the source of this page.
So you can see here that I--
in the middle
I just send a query
to the remote data source
called Simple Table.
Make this big
so you can read it.
So I send here a request
to Simple Table.
This is a servlet that
we saw before on the other page.
And I get the query--
sorry for that.
I send the query,
and when the response back--
coming back, I just get
the data from the response,
and process it
as if it's a normal data table.
And now I go on to
the CSV file.
So again we see here
the same thing.
The URL--
see the URL on top,
so it's myweb.csv--
slash csv,
but then I add another
parameter, URL parameter
called URL in this case,
which is the URL of
the CSV file.
So if I go to this file...
I just open a new window...
you can see just
a simple CSV file.
You can work with it,
you can do anything,
you can visualize data,
you can process it.
But with this tool now,
I have this CSV file
as a data source.
So I can add here--
sorry.
tqx.html...
and you see the same data--
this as a data table
that you can work with.
Let's do this.
I go to this playground,
which is a nice tool
that there is for all of the--
exists for all of
the Google APIs.
But in this case,
what I wanted to show you
is that I create--
I take this org chart and
I take this data from this URL.
So I just place this URL
as your data source URL
for a query.
You get to your response,
this table,
and I use this table to build
an organizational chart.
As you can see here,
the same data--
this is the data
taken from the CSV file.
And going back here...
So a few last things.
First of all about the query.
So you saw that the query
working here,
but I didn't do anything
with it.
So the default mode
is that we assume that
you don't know how to do
the query language,
which is true in most cases.
So what we are doing
is we're taking the data tables
that you generate on your side
after--
that you return in the generate
data table function.
And on top of this data table,
we apply the query that
the user specified.
But in some cases,
you might want to do it
from your side.
A good example is that--
let's say that you have
very huge table.
And you don't want to return
to create all of it
because it has,
I don't know, maybe it froze.
And you do know how
to filter them.
So if you want to--
if the user specified,
I don't know,
some values of some row limit,
you do want to get
this information
and do it on your own,
on your side.
So you can do it.
You can take the query
and apply the parse
that you know how to apply
on your side
before you return
the data table
to the library from
this table--
from this method.
But in this case,
you have to override a method
called GetCapabilities.
So you just--
this one here.
The default is none.
But if you know that
you can--
you know how to select rows
or select columns
or any other thing,
you should mention it.
So we don't do the same thing
on top of your data table.
So this is one thing and...
this is the Data Source
servlet.
You see that the only thing
that you have to do
after you implement it
is to override the generate
data table method,
which is defined
in the data table
generator interface.
And maybe the last
important thing
in this library for now
is this class called
Data Source helper.
So it is--
this class is the main API
that you need to use
if you don't want to just
implement a servlet,
as we saw before.
Let's say that
you don't use servlets.
You use maybe,
I don't know, any kind of--
another framework you see
or any other thing
that you don't work with
with simple servlets.
So this is like
a lower level API.
You can do everything
from here,
and this is being used
by the servlet we saw before.
The way it's implemented,
it has a few sets
of static methods
that deals with several,
as you can see here,
deal with servlet
or deal with how to create
the response or how to apply
the query language
at the bottom here.
It tells everything
that you need
in order to work with it.
So you don't really need to care
about all of the classes
in this library.
This is your main API.
If you use it
and there are examples,
you can see how it's used.
You can work--
if you need not to work
with servlet
but with some other stuff,
then this is the way
that you should use it.
This is the class to use,
and I just close everything
so you can see the method,
but as you see here,
they are documented quite well.
And again, it's open source
so you can see
the actual implementation.
So this is very useful.
I think that's about it
for now.
I want to call Jesse Lorenz
from Salesforce.
They implemented their own
data source,
and he will explain about it
now.
Thank you.
Lorenz: Thank you, Itai.
So my name is Jesse Lorenz,
and I'm a technical evangelist
from salesforce.com.
And I primarily work with
independent software vendors
that are looking to build
an architect application
on the force.com platform.
So some of you might not
be entirely familiar
with salesforce.com and
the force.com platform,
so I'm gonna use just--
let me go through a little bit
of terminology right now,
so we're all on the same page.
But before I do that,
I want to talk about--
I want to tell you
what I'm gonna talk about today.
So there's really two paths
of the Google visualization
API.
So there's actually
the visualizations themselves,
the annotated timelines,
the heat maps,
all that good stuff.
And then as Itai spent a lot
of time talking about today,
there's also the data sources.
So back in November,
Google and salesforce.com
started a partnership,
and we released a set
of components that allow you
to imbed the Google
visualizations inside of
your force.com
or Salesforce CRM apps.
Today I'm really excited
to announce that salesforce.com
is also now a Google
visualization data source.
So we'll talk about that
in a little bit more depth
in a moment.
But first,
just to make sure
everyone's on the same page
with me here,
Salesforce CRM is our suite
of customer relationship
management applications.
We've got over a million users
that are using it today
to market and sell
and support
their products
more effectively.
Now below that is
the force.com platform
and infrastructure.
So force.com allows developers
to go ahead and build
their own applications
on top of our infrastructure.
So this is very similar
to what Google's done
with Google App Engine
in allowing you to build
applications on top
of Google's infrastructure.
That's what force.com is.
It lets you build
your own business applications
on top of our infrastructure.
So I'm gonna talk about
two components of force.com
today.
So force.com is a complete
development stack.
It's delivered on demand
as a service.
And I'm gonna talk about
two components today.
One is Visualforce.
And Visualforce is what
we refer to as
our user interface
as a service.
It's our markup language
that provides you
with a bunch of pre-built
components
that ultimately
gets translated into HTML.
And then we're also
gonna talk about Apex,
which is one portion
of our logic as a service layer.
And it actually allows you
to write and run code
on our servers on demand.
It's a very Java-like
language.
You'll see a lot of similarities
here in a moment.
So enough talking.
I want to show you
some of the demos.
Hopefully,
that's enough background.
And the first thing
that I want to show you
is how we're already using
the visualizations
inside of Salesforce today.
So here's my login.
I'm gonna log in to
a sample org for Salesforce.
And what you can see
is that Salesforce
actually has its own
analytics engine.
We allow you
to do reporting
and to create
your own visualizations
just by pointing
and clicking.
We've got gauges, pie charts.
Pretty much all
the standard visualizations.
But one of the really
exciting things
is that with our new release
coming out in June
in just a few weeks from now,
you can actually embed
Visualforce pages
inside of your dashboards
as well.
And this is an example
of the annotated
timeline component
inside of a Visualforce page
displayed on your dashboard.
And as you can see here,
we've got two different
salespeople,
and you can see that
they have
fairly widely divergent
performance.
And so if we want to,
we can zoom in,
we can take a look
and start playing with
the annotated timeline
just like
you're used to using it.
And so this makes our dashboards
even more interactive.
We think it's really great
to have Google visualizations
inside of Salesforce.
So I did the demo.
And also,
I'm really excited.
This opens up brand new
use cases
to the force.com
development community.
I'm really excited to announce
that force.com
is now a Google visualization
data source.
So what I'm gonna focus on today
is unauthenticated access
to your force.com
or your Salesforce CRM data.
So I think this is really neat
because I think what
we've seen recently
is that there's really
a move towards
greater transparency
in our society.
So I think you might have seen
that Google released
the ability to go in
and drill into housing data,
housing sales price data,
and unemployment data
across the nation.
And so you can start
going in and looking at that.
And recently, data.gov
was just released as well,
which exposes a whole bunch more
census data.
And so people are able
to go in,
look at that data,
visualize it,
and understand it more.
And this is another step
toward that transparency.
And now companies
can actually go out
and start exposing
their internal data.
And we thought about this.
We thought, "Boy, there's just
a whole bunch of use cases
that are really interesting
here."
So if you're in marketing
and you're putting on
a conference like Google I/O,
you might want to put out
a heat map that shows where
all your different users
are coming from
so that they can figure out
if they're gonna be able
to make connections from
their home stage
or their home country.
You know if you're in sales,
you might want to expose
your product list.
You might want to expose
your most popular products
just like Amazon does, right?
They list the top books
that are being sold today.
With force.com as
a visualization data source,
that's really easy.
That's ten lines of code.
Your company can do that
as well.
And finally, the use case
that I'm gonna go through today
is also being able
to expose your support data.
So the sample that
I'm gonna walk through
in just a moment here
is actually at a call center
where you can actually start
to expose your call volumes
proactively to your users.
So let's take a look at
what that might be.
So I've mocked this up
for the California Department
of Motor Vehicles.
This isn't real.
This is a demo.
They're not doing this today.
But you can see that
here's the page, right?
So if I wanted to call the DMV,
you could use that number.
You could do that right now
if you're really bored.
But the call volume for today
can be displayed down at
the bottom.
And this is really interesting,
right?
For two reasons.
Because if I'm calling the DMV,
I can take a look and say,
"All right, it looks like
it might be a bad time
"to call the DMV.
"I don't really want
to sit on the phone.
"I'm probably just gonna
call tomorrow morning at 8:00.
"I'll get right in,
I'll talk to someone.
I'll be done."
It's also an advantage
because if people
start doing that,
then the utilization
of your call center
should smooth out, right?
So I think this is
a really powerful example
of your data source.
If you're using your internal
Salesforce CRM
or force.com data,
and exposing it to
the public.
And so I want to show you
how easy that is.
And to do that,
we can look at the page source
for this page.
I've simplified it
a little bit here
so that we can all
understand it.
But up at the top, we've got
some really basic styling.
And the interesting parts
are really this JavaScript here,
right?
So we're gonna load
the JavaScript API
for the visualizations.
And then we're also going to--
what Itai showed before,
we're also gonna create
this query object.
And again, here's the URL
to our data source.
And this is public.
You can go to this right now.
I'd encourage you not to
since it's kind of
a small developer instance.
But we can actually--
we can take this data source
right here--
copy that "E" as well--
and we can see the data
that's being returned
by this endpoint.
And so there it is.
So--
And we didn't have to
do anything
in order to generate this.
This is all being generated
for us.
And if we want to see
what that looks like visually,
we can go over to iGoogle
here.
And we can drag our force.com
data source
into a gadget on iGoogle.
So paste the URL there.
And we'll hit Save.
And you can see all
the different fields
that are available to us
at this endpoint.
But one of the things
that we've done
is we've actually
added a query,
or we've implemented
parts of the query language here
so that you can start
filtering and you can specify
the columns that
you want to return,
you can specify order bys
and limits
and things like that.
And so to give you
an example of that,
I will add that tq parameter
that Itai mentioned before,
and we'll select the hour
and the number of calls.
Oops.
Oh. Looks like we've got
an error there.
So that was really simple.
So that was really simple
to do, to wire that up,
that visualization.
But let me show you
the code that we had to write.
And I'm gonna go in.
This is the force.com IDE.
This is the integrated
development environment
for force.com applications.
And I'm gonna go to that page.
My endpoint there called
volume.
And you can see there's
not a lot on this page.
This is Visualforce here.
It might be unfamiliar
but we can understand it.
So the important thing here
is that there's a controller
behind this page
that follows the model-view-
controller architecture.
There's a controller
called call volume
data source controller.
And through this syntax,
we're calling a method
called GetResponse.
And so if we take a look at
that controller that's behind
our Visualforce page,
we can look at the methods
that we had to implement
in order to expose
this data source.
So there's two methods here.
There's get table name.
So I'm querying
the call volume table.
And then I've also exposed
a list of default columns,
and I've got five here--
the I.D. of the record,
the name of the record,
date, hour, and the number
of calls.
So that's pretty much
all you have to do
from a code perspective
to expose a data source
at force.com as a data source
to Google visualizations.
One of the things
that I haven't shown here
is that there's also
some security
that you're gonna need
to set up, of course.
You probably don't want
to go and expose
all of your accounts
and contacts and leads
to the public internet.
And so you can do that.
You can prevent that
from happening by just going in
and setting
the security settings
using our default
implementation,
our tried and true tested
decade-old security methodology.
And so none of what you see here
is actually security code.
You don't have to worry
about that at all.
So I'm very excited
about this.
I'm very excited about
the fact
that with just about
ten lines of code
you can start making
your force.com applications
into data sources as well
for Google visualizations.
And if you'd like
to learn more,
I would encourage you
to go to developerforce.com.
And I think we're ready
for questions.
Is that right, Itai?
Raz: So...
And that's about it.
So again, if you need
any more information, so--
there is detailed documentation
and many examples,
user group and everything
on our side.
Just Google
for Google visualization.
I hope you'll find it useful.
Thank you.
And if you have any questions.
[applause]
Lorenz: And I think if
you do have questions,
it would be great if
you could use the microphone
for the recording.
man: So with the querying
over the data sources,
are there WHERE clauses
in that query syntax?
Raz: Yeah.
man: And if it's implemented
over a CSV file,
say, through
the Java library,
are indexes built
for very large files,
and where are those
indexes stored?
Raz: So no, there is
no indexing for CSV files
at the moment.
Not in the implementation
that there is in the library.
Again, it's open source,
so it's something that can be
added later
or by your own,
but there is no indexing.
But yes, there is
a WHERE clause.
You can filter out with WHERE
and there is ordering--
order by group, by pivot,
column selection,
calculate the column,
and so on.
man: Okay, so it would be
pretty straightforward.
There's a method
that you could override
that does probably
a linear search right now,
but you could have it
use an index instead.
Raz: So the index
that you'd like to use,
I guess, is when you build
the data table
from the CSV file,
but now it's not implemented
with anything.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Instead of taking us
through a SQL query,
could you call
a stall procedure?
Raz: No.
So the current implementation
for MySQL
means that you have
to specify the tables
that you want to use.
The good way to create
kind of the--
to use stall procedure,
I believe,
is to create a dynamic view
on the SQL side.
You can define a view
with some pretty fine selection,
and then you can refer to it
as a table.
So that would be it.
Yes?
man: I have two questions.
First one, just a general
historical question
about the protocol.
I was investigating, and
I know that there's something
called the DAP protocol
and also something called
OPeNDAP,
which is used in applications
for weather data
and also been applied
to astronomy data
and things like that.
And I'm wondering
if there's been some--
you're shaking your head no,
so you probably
didn't inves--
or maybe you're not familiar
with that.
But I'm wondering if
there's something that
was kind of a predecessor
or it was used as
an inspiration for
the protocol that's used
just to put it into context
for what--
so it's sort of generated
fresh from the ground up then?
Raz: Probably.
man: Okay.
Then the second question is,
if there's--
if we have a lot of data
that is not stored
in the CSV format,
so just a custom binary format,
what would be the technique
that we could use to make it
available for visualization?
Raz: So as we saw before,
you can just
implement the generate
data table
and you'll have to build
your own code.
But the nice thing is
all you have to do is
to generate a code
that takes this internal format
that you know
and create a data table object.
man: All right.
Raz: So you can take a look
at just the CSV implementation,
which is, by the way,
using some external code
called opencsv.
So it's an open source--
but generally speaking,
it's quite simple.
All you have--
if you already have the data
and you know how
to modulate it
to be a two-dimensional
table,
then you're set.
Build the actual Java coding
that needs to build
the data table
and add rows and columns
is very simple.
man: Right.
man: Hi.
Just a quick question about
the query language.
If I have a really dumb
data source
that I create myself
that's just producing
the JSON format for
the columns and the rows
with the data in it,
can I use the query language
on that?
Is that understanding correct?
That I can actually query
against a data source
that doesn't actually
implement
any of the query language?
Raz: So this is a data source
that you implemented?
man: Yes.
Raz: So it will not work
as is.
You'll have to implement
the data--
the query language.
So either
you can implement it--
look at the spec
and implement it,
or you may just take the--
if you use--
if it's Java based,
you may want to consider
to use this Java library
and to re-implement
your data source.
man: Okay, so when
you were saying that
the query language
doesn't expect--
well, I think I was reading
where it says that
the query language
doesn't expect the data source
to implement the full--
the full feature set
of the query language,
it just means that
you can just pick and choose
which parts you want to use.
Raz: We refer to
the data source--
to the query language as
an optional part of
the spec of the protocol.
Because we know it's quite hard
to implement it.
We did it.
So parsing it
and implementing it
is not that easy.
So you don't have to do it
to be a data source.
And in many cases,
if you want to be
the data source
of your own site,
so there is no real need
to do it.
You can use
your external parameters
and whatever you know to return
you just return it.
man: Okay. Thank you.
Raz: All right.
Go ahead.
Anyone else?
man: I have a question
about MySQL in particular.
So I'm curious about
with the query language,
are you actually
parsing the query
that's coming in
or with MySQL,
are you just passing that
through to MySQL?
I think about this just because
I have implemented something
which is similar.
I like your architecture
much better.
So I'm looking at porting
what would be
gobs of SQL that
I've already got.
Am I gonna have to make it
so that it's compatible to SQL,
as compatible with your SQL?
Raz: Yeah, okay,
this is a good question.
So what we are doing--
we actual parse the data
because we just wanted
to make sure that there is
no error in stuff like this
and so we parse it,
but we don't implement it.
What we are doing--
we parse this query to MySQL.
So we parse it on
the first end,
and then what we are doing--
we build SQL query
and send it to
the MySQL engine.
Okay?
So we parse it,
but we don't implement it.
Unless there is one case
that we do it on our end,
which is, for example,
the pivot.
So in our query language,
you can specify to people
we found it very useful.
So many times,
people have data of--
quarterly data and so on,
and it won't be able
to show quarters like this.
And MySQL, SQL in general,
does not support pivot,
which is a pity,
but this is the situation.
So in this case,
we have to do it on our side.
So we don't parse anything.
Or most of the case,
we don't parse anything
to MySQL,
but do it on our side.
But any other way,
if we see that--
to create something
that SQL can deal with,
we'll pass it on to you.
man: That's great.
I didn't realize you guys
were doing that.
That's really good to know.
So are there any limitations
in terms of,
if you think of sort of
the body of SQL
that something like
MySQL could handle,
whether it's unions
or different types of joins
or really complex
or verbose SQL.
Raz: Yeah.
So for now,
joins and unions
are not part of
the query language.
So you'll have to create
a pretty fine view
on your data source,
on your database
and call it as a data table
from our side.
This is one thing.
But as about the size
of the data,
usually it doesn't make sense
to pass the data
that is more than
a few thousand across
to the browser.
It will just take a long time
to be processed
and to be sent to the browser.
And usually most visualizations
don't know how to show
such an amount of data.
So you'd better send some kind
of grouping information
or filtering in
the query language.
man: Okay. Thank you.
Raz: All right.
Okay, thank you, everybody.
Are there any other questions?
Okay, so--
[applause]
I don't know.
You can come here maybe
and ask later.
Okay, thank you.
[applause]